we all ready to
start let's the game begins how was that
that was kind of actually
dramatic so we'll continue with our game
10 last game actually really interesting
world championship match was two short
one finished two games before I think K
canand was six and a half four and a
half kamik Anan topalo six and a half
five and a half Anan G
66 okay but this one yeah Caron with
white expecting I spoke with Ben
Sicilian Bishop B5 everything's written
everything's known everything is out
there nothing is new Under the Sun like
it says okay I play this with white
black any color that is in the rainbow
you want to play for simple chest
reasonably Bishop D7 yeah white can play
and he can take and go C4 or whatever
lines okay it's supposed to be kind of
solid line and okay you want really to
keep your winning chances Knight C6 or
KN D7 so Knight D7 no surprise there
either
D4 actually they already played a game
like this they already played a game
like this uh uh in London I believe let
me
actually get this one
yeah Knight F6 Bishop G5 I mean if if
Knight C3 black might have the
possibility to actually play this way
which might be a somewhat favorable way
so Bishop G5 is possible there's a very
very similar
game actually if I'm not mistaken this
move was played in that game if I'm not
mistaken
and it's a game that ivanchuk killed
Kasparov in 91 I think it was linar he
won he beat Kasparov and kpov I think it
was May maybe first tournament ever that
someone did it of course won the
tournament and of course if you would
have enough nerves he would be playing
for Big World Championship Match big not
like a yeah but what to do this is also
something we never we little bit spoke
about Carlson it's not only that he
remembers everything it's not only that
he calculates like he is like really the
full package like he is from nerves
point of view like some carpo that has
played I don't know how many world
championship matches and tournament I
mean that's this is the amazing thing
is no no weaknesses in that in that
sense I mean maybe all in all maybe it's
only weakness I I mean I think it can
really be bitten somehow by tactics
mainly
I mean and that's why I I think maybe
Nakamura is one that maybe tactically
can give him a decent shot I mean they
played here two floors up in the
singfield cup and the game with
black iaro outplayed him tactically iaro
outplayed him I mean gon with
a magical Fortress but okay those
magical things he found quite a lot but
he made a
draw okay so what do we have here we
have a very noral
position pair of Bishops for black but
is it really horrible to give away this
bishop is it really horrible to give
away this bishop when you have those
pawns here here a very typical very
typical move to the position was play
here which which which move what what
what do we know about this
position
the big question is where do white put
his rugs
right yes but but before that wh wh wh
white want to get something else done
before he's even going to discuss where
he's going to put his
work why
H3 uh he doesn't want the knight kicking
something off of e3 at bish
back yeah but but but then he has a way
to fix it in to fix it he he he really
wants to find a spot for this Knight
oops and and and if 86 maybe get the
queen of the diagonal so some
possibilities he might be able to put
better pressure on
D6 it's a very typical move in those
position very typical the Knight will go
to D4 very very typical and then the
pawn can move to F3 in several positions
and you get kind of your normal
structure how to win it with black not
so
easy like we said this kid knows how to
play chess well I mean while we're
seeing this game he still not the world
champion now he has to get all the
respect CU he deserve
it okay so he takes and here interesting
I thought if to play for a
win maybe I would take with the
Pawn maybe maybe I will take with with
the pawn if I'm here
to to play for a
win Queen
take Rook C1
86 your move R if you're you're take
with the pawn there be your ideas
for
okay you know I I wasn't expecting this
follow off
question no I I'm joking I'm joking of
course I think that what I would like to
do is this I would like to play C5
yeah or E5 most likely C5 in a perfect
world and then play this
maneuver yes if I can get this structure
I will feel better I don't think it's
really that easy but if I can play here
let's and and let's say that I kick you
and you go here
okay okay here I take black I will make
effort maybe I'll put the bishop here
I'll control this spot maybe I'll think
about F5 in right moment even here maybe
not gigantic but this is why I want to
take towards the center this is the my
idea and this we get those
structures I mean I can tell you hey I
might want to work really hard and think
of a D5 break what's the problem here if
you want to play for a win even if you
play D5 and take take take take put a
rook on D5 how are you going to win this
position yeah all the pieces are coming
yeah and and and you will get rid of the
minor pieces and Rook end games it's
going to be tough I mean okay it's it's
really tough to win this maybe that's
why Carson play this I mean but but it's
not like playing for completely playing
for door he's playing chess in an
extreme solid
position I I I wonder if something like
this is
legit I'm not certain but oh yeah I I I
I think I tricked Ben when we did the
analysis he took and I play this that's
not that's not a bad way to finish the
game
yeah 97 I mean this you see our ideas
trans transferring the Knight here there
okay
okay okay the queen goes to A5 okay
nothing
dramatic all right aha what is the
threat
here Knight
D5 kn95 is a very decent threat exactly
so Bishop f8 is the more normal move
that we were that we were little bit
expecting Bishop D5 was the more normal
move that we were expecting
and King f8 a bit more
interesting so we were joking if we can
go back with the king or not and so on
boom and and Ben said no way no way in
the world that car will go back because
then Bishop e will be played we were
entertaining the following idea that
that's the great thing about doing
commentary you know you never get
nervous you not only that you can
sacrifice the other people pieces
sometimes when I watch the game as a fan
I'm much more nervous than than a
commentator you know commentator I have
to tell you I have to be I don't want to
look at this position I I'm taking side
but this is all
right just all right but
but A4 I by the way I wouldn't play this
move we spoke I think it's tiny
weakening playing A4 is not really
scared and he really wants to stop B5 I
thought there's maybe a more chicken way
to play but no okay that's why I'm am
just a retired Grandmaster out of few
thousands and not the
best player maybe in history Queen H5
Knight
E2 okay Rook
C3 Rook
C3 yes 50/50 to lose the game if he
takes with the Knight it's
over we we were
joking but now something serious that is
not joking why actually tiny bit managed
to obtain some small
Advantage small but but okay the thing
is that here if you offer a draw maybe
in this position you would accept
because it's not clear yet if he's
better or not A5 dude that's a move Ben
was B Ben was right on I mean I give him
all credit because he deserve it saying
look at their faces those are not people
that think they're going to finish the
game like you know like you are slightly
slightly worse slightly maybe a draw and
you play some Russian grandmas and
suddenly he goes and brings like a big
cup of tea and you said oh man that's
going to be a long game you know he's
coming there with a long cup of tea and
you said okay forget about any dreams of
maybe making a draw no no so this A5 is
not a big cup of tea but it's the same
story but okay joking no joking I mean
this position is roughly equal maybe
Queen C5 maybe Rook
d8 this position is roughly roughly
equal but what is this move now now
seriously what is this move blunder
first of all embarrassing
blunder
like this is blunder number four that
was not punished maybe maybe part of the
situation maybe if this was game one the
result of the game might be different
because when Carson was asked well there
was this was better he said it's not not
really that important now but which move
will should we play in this
position you should be on un team for
the candidates
E5 E5
like okay what what happens if Rook
take Knight C4 Knight takes C4 very good
very good we we are doing good today you
know so but after
E5 okay Caron took quite quickly
let's see the time
5544 yuck 25 seconds and this actually
turns out okay this is a blunder he
should be probably losing the game like
losing computers one and a half one what
no no no no joke like and this shows
more than all you know the gentleman was
asking me well Anand was so good yes
he's amazing it you know Michael Jordan
was not a very bad basketball player how
was this
comeback it's also right I mean the less
painful than some boxers that have made
come so I there there there it is I I
guess that there is a point that all the
this is why in some way you know
Kasparov did
something wow you need to have I'm not
saying it because it will be broadcast
to say he he really left at the very
Peck that's kind of like you you don't
say oh you know like we speak about carp
of say okay you know we deteriorated so
much spasy did even better spasy after
lost the world championship pretty much
didn't care he's such a genius great
player but enjoyed life played some
chess I think he he move to to France
play like like tennis exactly tennis
golf that's he was never known to be one
of the hardest working ones but so so he
did it while in motion Kasparov yeah
Kasparov decided that he wants to be in
uh that he wants to be fighting with
Putin instead of other things okay take
computer suest say this move the problem
is is just heading this way and the
pressure on D6 is unbearable when the
queen goes to d8 it's going to Triple
quadruple it's going to attack it like I
don't know 17 times they're only 16
pieces so no but going to take it with
everything this computer is a big
Advantage yeah is get is F4 once again
perfect perfect he can play Rook D3
and exchange everything but he can do it
like Magnus Caron would do now now no in
some end games now I'm not joking you
think you put computer Houdini no it's
usually first Magnus then Houdini I'm
actually I've seen several complicated
it's
unbelievable
unbelievable okay of course of course if
the Knight could be could this would be
still a game and actually this move
would be proven to be just wrong because
it weakens the king big time I mean this
black can play the problem is Tiny
problem that it just loses the
game
yeah this is the only only problem in
this
position so they got this end game which
is not extremely entertaining and we can
analyze this but we're not going to do
it that
much white white is better of course is
caning get to C5 and okay I was just you
know that that was the part I think it
was like 6 in the morning six in a bit
that I was starting to say okay so which
creative ideas do I see in the position
okay this this and then I was starting
to say to show some ideas like okay so
now I will play this like making effort
to find many interesting positions like
this was doing it all over yeah that's
what you do with uh when you're
ridiculously sleep deprived and doing
those plus okay the end game itself is I
will say this if the score here was five
and a half five and a half it would have
been like no we nobody would be we would
not be making those jokes like because
white is better white has to see if he
can win or
not there it's like okay you're a
commentator in a basketball game and it
happens sometime in fourth quarter one
team is 35 points ahead no what are you
going to wow look at okay you know you
you start speaking about history about
the game the father of the player the
mother of the player because here it's
over black has zero chances to win but
once again Anan cannot offer a draw
because if he would be rejected
it's wow Carlson would not offer a draw
because well one it's tiny bit well
actually Ben said that Carlson is the
one that can offer a draw
yeah but he doesn't just doesn't want to
do it I mean I guess it's reasonable you
are the Challenger you are much better
you're giving the World Champ say I
don't want necessarily to beat you last
game okay they played what they played
and there were some lines here that very
very long lines I I'll just mention that
this move was absolutely the the best
best suggestion and there were some
lines white is better but uh most likely
the game white is white can go to a
queen end game when he's better but
again uh if we will look at that it will
just be missing the point Carlson just
SE that he can he said it was too
difficult complicated and okay just play
this check
check yeah some some friends of mine on
ICC I mean the grand Masters there uh um
no they were analyzing it and kind of I
mean very strong Grand Masters and and
some scary dudes yo and Larry
Christiansen so do they I'll say
something wrong you know they'll sneeze
at me and I'm gone but no they were
analyzing it and saying okay no trying
to make it somewhat interesting but dude
if white loses all his pawns unless it
is some amazing composition that you
give check check check check check check
and find some position for checkm or a
fork it's completely over
Che yeah and here Magnus said okay I not
play King G6 King H6
sorry check check and here finding the
fastest way to eliminate this and not
even capturing back there is no
Checkmate on the board
and amazing new well amazing new world
champion not so amazing because it was
for people out of Chess World it's so
exciting wow and but for people in Chess
World the facto Magnus Carson is best
player in the world by rating by every
standard by tournament so it was
just approval of everything that has
been done already uh Mark wther in the
week in chess wrote that you know after
the singfield cup right here it's always
great to say it because this this
building I I will always I had um dinner
with WX on Tuesday they had dinner and
they were kind to invite me and I told
him you know it will always be
remembered that the singfield cup was
the last tournament of Carson before
becoming world champion so it's always
here but Mark rer wrote that okay that
Carson is headed for a date with Destiny
I thought it was really right on because
it's not it's not Gund Gund was a
miracle that is there for Caron it was
really Destiny Destiny for exactly 10
years
20034 there was nothing else that
written in the Des book other than him
becoming world champion and oh that's
why amazing he did it and you know me
and Ben and few others will get some
sleep and uh after this match that 3:30
I I I was just joking that I hope
whoever is going to play next that the
match is not going to be in
India
a